[Musik]
Krieg in Nahost Gefahr für die Welt das
fragen wir uns heute und damit einen
guten Abend liebe Zuschauer der Westen
allen voran die USA drängt Israel seine
Bodenoffensive weiter zu verschieben
auch weil die Amerikaner erst noch
Truppen in die Region verlegen müssen
denn Israel wird nach dem Massaker auch
aus dem Libanon und aus Syrien
angegriffen das Entsetzen über die viel
Opfer im Gazastreifen steigt vor der UN
und in Europa wird um Worte und um
Hilfen gerungen und Hass auf Israel
zeigt sich auch auf Deutschlands Straßen
wie gefährlich ist die Lage im Nahen
Osten und wie gefährlich ist sie für die
Welt wir müssen reden mit diesen Gästen
der ZDF Moderator und israelkenner
Christian
sias die Menschenrechtsaktivistin Düsen
tkal Christian Mölling
Militärexperte und im Einzelinterview
Joachim Gauk Bundespräsident
aD sie sind zu Gast bei Maybritt ilner
und sie begrüßt alle Gäste dieser
Sendung sehr herzlich die Lage
verschärft sich im Grunde an allen
Fronten die Angst vor dem
Flächenbrand letzte Nacht dringt die
israelische Armee in Gaza ein Hamas
Stützpunkte werden zerstört
das T für die Bodenoffensive
ausgekundschaftet dann ziehen sich die
Israelis
[Musik]
zurück wir bereiten uns auf eine
Bodenoffensive vor ich werde nicht sagen
wann und wie sie stattfindet und wie
umfangreich sie sein
wird doch mit Gaza endet die Bedrohung
nicht experten sehen bereits eine zweite
Front im Norden
Israels ein böses Omen das Treffen
zwischen Hamas
is jetzt entsenden die USA zusätzlich
Kampfgeschwader und Luftabwehrraketen in
die
Region doch auch die Bilder aus Gaza
erzeugen internationalen
Druck diplomatisch leise aus Washington
oder per Paukenschlag aus New
York steht über dem internationalen
humanitären
recht Antonio guteris fühlte sich
missverstanden darüber werden wir noch
sprechen fangen wir zunächst mit der
Situation an Christian Mölling bei uns
Sicherheitsexperte
verteidigungsexperte wie gefährlich ist
in ihren Augen die Situation also ich
glaube man muss vielleicht vor die
klammmer ziehen der existenzielle
Konflikt für Europa zum jetzigen
Zeitpunkt ist immer noch der russische
Angriffskrieg in der Ukraine das B
bedeutet nicht dass das was jetzt zur
Zeit in Israel und Gaza passiert nicht
das Potenzial hat tatsächlich mehr zu
erzeugen ich will das den Begriff vom
Flächenbrand nicht benutzen ich glaube
der ist ja abgegriffen aber es besteht
natürlich das Risiko dass weitere
Akteure das weitere akteurere in den
Konflikt eingreifen dass der Libanon mit
dazu kommt aber nicht also nicht der
Libanon sondern die hbolla aus dem
Libanon heraus und andere Akteure
möglicherweise aus Syrien heraus mit in
den Konflikt eingreifen damit die Lage
militärisch schwieriger wird aber auch
die Fr was ist dann das richtige
Verhalten der Europäer in dem
Zusammenhang auch der Amerikaner wird
deutlich schwieriger jetzt sieht es noch
sehr einfach aus in Anführungsstrichen
man hat den Eindruck man wüsste wer auf
der richtigen oder falschen Seite ist
das ändert sich augenblicklich wenn mehr
Akteure ins Spiel kommen man gar nicht
sagen kann was ist eigentlich noch die
Lösungsoption die man jetzt noch
anbieten kann die Vereinigten Staaten
spielen eine große Rolle in diesem
Konflikt wir haben verstanden dass die
Hamas weiter versucht auf israelischen
Boden zu kommen dass ist diese
vermehrten Luftangriffe aus dem Norden
durch die Hisbollah gibt welche Chance
hat Israel sich zu verteidigen mit dem
berühmten iron Dome und wie sehr
bräuchte sie in der Zukunft eben dann
auch die Amerikaner allein für die
Luftabwehr die Amerikaner spielen jetzt
vor allen Dingen im sousagen in dem
größeren Kontext in der Absicherung eine
Rolle weil sie mit der Verlagerung des
Militärs jetzt in die Region tatsächlich
ein abschreckungspotenzial gegen die
Hamas möglicherweise auch gegen andere
staatliche Akt
Iran bilden und sagen das lassen wir
jetzt besser erstmal für sich da haltet
ihr euch raus die Hilfe was irondome
angeht klar das ist ein das bleibt ein
Problem aber DAH hinter steht ja im
Grunde genommen eigentlich das größere
israelische Problem dass ihnen
schlagartig mit dem Terroranschlag der
Hamas bewusst geworden ist dass sie ein
riesiges Sicherheitsproblem haben und
dass sie das grundversprechen des
israelischen Staates nämlich Sicherheit
für Israelis zu bieten nicht einlösen
können was ja ganz besonders ist in
dafür ist dieser Staat gegründet worden
und das heißt sie sind eigentlich in dem
Dilemma das jetzt grundlegend ist für
alles weitere sie können nicht sagen wir
lassen das jetzt einfach auf sich
beruhen denn die Hamas schießt immer
noch täglich Raketen aus dem Gebiet es
gibt hamaskämpfer die immer noch
versuchen über die Grenze zu kommen das
heißt das Sicherheitsproblem ist nicht
vorbei dadurch dass es einen Anschlag
gegeben hat der Krieg aus Sicht der is
geht weiter und da ist ein
Sicherheitsempfinden zu tiefst zerstört
und erschüttert wenigstens Christian
sieers ist bei uns ZDF Moderator und
Kollege und für 5 Jahre in Tel Aviv als
Korrespondent des zweiten deutschen
Fernsehens genau dahin gefragt diese
Regierung Nano die ja auch schon im Amt
war als du da unten warst und Bericht
erstattet hast wie sehr ist die jetzt
auch unter dem Druck ihrer eigenen
Bevölkerung und ist irgendwie abzusehen
ob und wie lange Netanyahu eben noch
derjenige ist der nicht nur das
kriegskabinett führt sondern am Ende
auch dieses Land noch regiert na die
Regierung netanahu ist unter erheblichem
Druck von zwei Seiten auf der einen
Seite muss sie die Geiseln unverletzt
freiekommen auf der anderen Seite muss
sie Hamas schlagen das sind zwei Ziele
die sich eigentlich ausschließen die die
zumindest unglaublich schwer werden
gleichzeitig zu erreichen und dann kommt
der dritte Punkt den aber die Israelis
im Moment noch zurückstellen nämlich die
Frage nach der Verantwortung und nach
demem was schief gelaufen ist denn wer
mal im Gazastreifen war der weiß wie gut
gesichert Grenze ist da hat man immer
ein ganzen Tag in der Kontrolle
festgesetzen weil die Israelis wirklich
alles kontrolliert haben inklusive
Durchleuchtung da steht ein Zaun der
angeblich eine Milliarde Euro gekostet
hat der 10 m tief in den Boden
reingerammt wurde damit bloß niemand aus
Gaza nach Israel kann deswegen ist es
mit allen ich war jetzt vor anderthalb
Wochen in Tel Aviv mit allen mit den ich
da geredet habe die sagen es ist uns
völlig unerklärlich wie das passieren
konnte und da wird auch die Regierung
noch ganz viele Fragen beantworten
müssen den das ist ja das Tolle an
Israel ist ja eine sehr lebendige
Demokratie hat eine sehr lebendige
Presse die übrigens jetzt schon genau
diese Fragen stellt wie konnte es dazu
kommen wir sind dankbar dass Düsen
tecker heute bei uns ist
Menschenrechtsaktivistin Journalistin
sie sind Düsen in Kontakt mit
Angehörigen von Geiseln die durch die
hammas immer noch
festgehalten werden und nun gibt's vier
Frauen die freigelassen wurden was löst
das unter diesen Angehörigen aus ich
glaube es ist ganz wichtig zu verstehen
dass die Angehörigen auch in
Gefangenschaft sind also die sind in
emotionaler Gefangenschaft und mich hat
die Begegnung auch mit den Angehörigen
der Geiseln an is Gefangene erinnert und
ihre
Angehörigen ich glaube wie tief diese
Verwundbarkeit und die Schutzlosigkeit
sitzt die erfährt man erst in der
gegenüberschaft mit diesen Menschen und
für mich zeigt das auch noch mal den
Unterschied zwischen terroror ismus und
Krieg und das was diesen Menschen
passiert ist ist Terror und ich glaube
das muss man immer wieder auch
hervorholen und betonen weil das
vergessen wird weil gegenwärtig so getan
wird als wenn man immer nur über eine
Seite spricht das passiert auf
gegenseitiger Seite genauso aber
tatsächlich ist es so dass insbesondere
für jüdische Menschen der Raum im Moment
immer enger wird und zwar auch in
Deutschland und das merken wir
gegenwärtig auch und über Deutschland
reden wir gleich no genau aber es ist
ist sozusagen schrecklich was den dort
wiederfahren ist das ist das größte
Verbrechen seit der chois und das hat
sich ins kollektive Gedächtnis
eingebrannt also unter den Gefangenen
sind Holocaust Überlebende die die
einsatzgruppenerschießung Deutschlands
überlebt haben und dann im Vorgarten
wieder erschossen worden sind und das
muss man sich vergegenwärtigen und das
Gefährliche daran ist dass die Saat des
Terrors nämlich der Samen der Angst der
ist eigentlich schon aufgegangen und
zwar nicht nur im mittleren Nahen Osten
sondern aus meiner Sicht auch weltweit
und das merkt man auch daran äh wie man
dafür unter Druck gesetzt wird wenn man
darüber berichtet bzw was können
jüdische Deutsche dafür was sozusagen
die Regierung gerade macht also wenn man
sie dafür haftbar macht dann ist das
tiefer Antisemitismus auf der anderen
Seite und das ist jetzt ganz wichtig
findet gerade Luftangriffe statt auf die
Hammers aber wir können nicht
ausschließen und das ist die
militärische Wahrheit dass Zivilisten
auch getroffen werden und und in
Größenordnung darunter leiden bleiben
wir noch mal bei den Geiseln Herr
Mölling für eine Sekunde oder auch für
ja vier also zwei Amerikanerinnen zwei
israelinen sind freigelassen worden
welche Strategie der Herm steckt
dahinter man weiß nicht was im
Hintergrund alles an Gesprächen abläuft
aber sie haben es eigentlich gerade
finde ich sehr gut beschrieben die die
Strategie der Hamas wird nicht sein die
Geisen wegzugeben weil das sozusagen
wichtiges faustfand ist genauso wie sie
die Palästinenser quasi aus der
Geiselhaft nicht entlassen wird weil man
will diese Bilder haben man will ja
gerade der Kampf ist Kampf der Bilder
vom ersten Tag im Grund angewesen mit
allen Mitteln und Kniffen der
Desinformation und auch dem dem Versuch
ein ganz anderes Ziel zu verfolgen als
die Israelis die ihre Sicherheit
wiederherstellen müssen hier ist der
Versuch im Grunde den Terror zu
verlängern und den Erfolg den man ja
schon gehabt hat mit dem mit dem ersten
riesigen Terrorangriff im Grunde
genommen soweit es wie geht eigentlich
immer weiter zu verlängern und damit
im Grunde genommen diesen Krieg und und
den den Sieg im Grunden für sich weiter
feiern zu können
christian war in äh Israel als Gilet
schalb freigelassen wurde das war dieser
eine Rekrut gegen den 1027 1027
palästinensische Häftlinge aus
israelischen Gefängnissen ausgetauscht
wur lassen wurde auch an Dich die Frage
nach der Strategie der Hamas du sagst
genau das will man Hamas hat damals
gemerkt erstens wir können mit Israel
verhandeln Israel verhandelt mit uns so
rum
und wir können von Israel einen sehr
sehr hohen Preis erreichen für die
Freilassung eine einzelnen Rekruten ja
wenn man sich das vorstellt man kann man
vielleicht so ein bisschen sich klar
machen was das jetzt bedeutet einerseits
für Hamas andererseits aber auch für die
israelische Gesellschaft dieses Trauma
es war damals so dass angila Chalid
überall erinnert wurde in den
Fernsehnachrichten immer wieder gesagt
wurde Leute wir dürfen ihn nicht
vergessen er ist immer noch in Gaza in
Gefangenschaft und da kann man sich
vielleicht so ein bisschen ermessen was
das jetzt für diese enorm große Zahl von
Geisel mit der israelischen ges macht
ich habe in Tel Aviv vor anderthalb
Wochen mit vielen Angehörigen von Geisel
geredet man möchte sich das ja selber
auch gar nicht vorstellen man kann es
sich glaube ich auch gar nicht
vorstellen dieses Gefühl machtlos zu
sein auf die Uhr zu gucken abzuwarten
nicht schlafen zu können was was sich
mir so eingebrannt hat ist da saßen bei
einer Pressekonferenz in einem Raum
wirklich sehr sehr viele hartgesottene
Kriegsberichterstatter muss man sagen
und die haben alle mit den Tränen
gekämpft also die Reporter und es war so
so eine Pressekonferenz bei der die die
Menschen auf dem Podium also die
Angehörigen der Geiseln sagten es ist
eigentlich ganz anders als eine normale
Pressekonferenz wir wollen nicht hier
sein wir hätten uns niemals ausdenken
können dass wir jemals auf so einem
Podium einer Pressekonferenz sprechen
müssen normalerweise ist eine
Pressekonferenz dafür da um irgendwas
bekannt zuug geben aber die sagten nein
wir wollen am liebsten zu Hause sein
aber eben mit unseren liebsten wieder
gesund zurück bei uns Israel kämpft um
die die Geiseln es gab jetzt heute das
Angebot dass man gegen 6000
Palästinenser
die
222 Geiseln freilassen würde die
Israelis haben Frage an Sie Ihre
Strategie da verändert und sind eben weg
von dem Gedanken mit einem großen
Bataillon und vielen
Streitkräften eine Bodenoffensive zu
starten sondern sind jetzt dabei
tatsächlich mit sogenannten
Kommandostrukturen
enthauptungsschläge zu machen gibt's
eine neue Strategie ähm also es gibt
zumindest eine Anpassung und ich glaube
man muss die ersten 48 Stunden in der
glaube ich auch schon der Begriff der
großen Bodenoffensive gefallen ist und
dann kamen die Bilder von den Panzern
das muss man trennen von dem was dann
folgt wo ja sozusagen die Politik sagt
das möchten wir erreichen das Militär
dann sagt können wir es erreichen was
ist eigentlich machbar und welche
Risiken bedeutet das eigentlich und
deswegen glaube ich wir sehen quasi
schon das was als Bodenoffensive am
Anfang möglich ist wo man sehr
vorsichtig vorgeht einfach auch weil man
ja nicht sagen kann jetzt nur weil
jemand gesagt hat wir fangen an und die
Panzer sind aufgefahen geht's los also
man wird ja versuchen die Verluste für
die eigenen Verbände seit wie möglich
runterzuhalten ebenso wie
wie bei den Zivilisten der der
Palästinenser ähm aber das ist eben die
Frage wie weit und das ist die wirklich
schwierige Aufgabe wie weit die
israelische Armee sagt
bei jedem einzelnen Schritt das können
wir wagen äh und wir riskieren das
dieses Haus zu zerschießen oder ob man
sagt ne wir lassen das weil es eben
Auswirkung auch entweder auf die Bilder
hat die ich produziere oder eben auf die
Frage kann ich die Geisel noch noch frei
beekommen oder muss ich sagen das ist
verloren man muss auch sagen wenn ich
das ganz kurzen da vielleicht Netanyahu
war bei all den bisherigen Gaza kriegen
und es gab ja leider eine ganze Reihe
davon immer eher der Zögerer immer eher
der vorsichtige man kann von ih halten
was man will aber es ist kein
Ministerpräsident der gesagt hat jetzt
gehen wir rein sofort sondern ist immer
eher einer derteigsminister auch galant
der das am Anfang gleich sagt genau no
ist einer der immer eher gesagt hat ich
muss abweggen und es gibt viele
israelische Kolleginnen und Kollegen bei
den großen Zeitungen in Israel die sagen
er vertraut auch seiner Armee nicht
hundertprozentig und vielleicht nachdem
was wir jetzt gerade gesehen haben noch
weniger so ich weiß nicht ob das stimmt
aber auch das wäre eine Erklärung dafür
dass diese angekündigte Offensive immer
weiter verschoben wird es geht aber um
noch eine Komponente und das ist auf
jeden Fall dass die Hamas den Krieg der
Bilder schon gewonnen hat und natürlich
WE wei Israel auch dass wenn es zu
dieser Bodenoffensive kommt zu welchen
Lasten das geht denn wir müssen noch mal
deutlich machen die Hamas profitiert von
jedem Toten leider auch von den eigenen
Toten es geht nicht nur um die 200
israelischen Geiseln es geht um 2
Millionen Palästinenser die als
Verhandlungsmasse missbraucht werden und
man riskiert das man riskiert den Tod
dieser Menschen weil Terror davon lebt
darum geht es noch mal da müssen wir
ganz klar unterscheiden das ist völlig
klar die Vereinten Nationen das haben
wir jetzt in den letzten zwei Tagen
verfolgt heute auch die europäische
ringt nicht nur nach Worten sondern auch
nach den Hilfen die die Menschen in Gaza
jetzt tatsächlich brauchen für das
Lebensnotwendigste den Bundeskanzler
zitierend ist er überzeugt davon dass
Israel die Vorschriften des
Völkerrechtes nicht nur akzeptiert
sondern auch umsetzen wird die ja
grausam genug sind man darf nicht extrem
eine bestimmte zivile Gruppe und und das
gilt das gilt tatsächlich weltweit für
jeden nichtdestotrotz befindet man sich
im Krieg und Krieg hat eigene Gesetze
und wir leben in Zeiten wo man zweimal
stirbt einmal physisch und dann noch mal
für die Propaganda und das ist sehr
vielen Akteuren klar aber für uns als
Menschenrechtsorganisation ist es
wichtig dass humanitäre Hilfe geleistet
wird und jedwies Menschenleben gleich
behandelt wird und dass Zivilisten
geschützt werden selbstverständlich auch
in Gaza aber der Verwaltungsapparat ist
in den Händen der Hamas und wenn wir z.B
die humanitäre Hilfe sprechen dann
können wir nicht auf humanitäre Hilfe
verzichten nur weil der Terror davon
profitiert weil dann trocknen wir nicht
den Terror aus sondern die Palästinenser
das heißt der Terrorismus bzw die Hamas
nährt sich davon wenn wir den Schmerz
der Palästinenser übersehen auf der
einen Seite und trotzdem geht es glaube
ich darum auch noch mal ein Bewusstsein
dafür zu schaffen dass Israel
angegriffen wird und zwar in seinen
Grundwerten und zwar an einem in einem
mehr frontenkrieg also wer von Syrien
gesprochen die ang auf Syrien sind ja
deswegen zustande gekommen weil Waffen
aus dem Iran kommen beispielsweise und
es geht sozusagen auch um die Existenz
auch wenn man das nicht hören will aber
darum geht es und deswegen macht das die
ganze Sache so kompliziert weil wir
natürlich ja im Grunde genommen mit
parallelwahrheiten mit der einen
Realität konfrontiert sind aber eben
auch mit der
zweiten Christian die humanitäre Hilfe
um die jetzt so gekämpft wird wo man
lange an Ägypten hingeredet hat wo man
sich wunderte dass arabische Regierung
so zögerlich sind außer im Wort dieas zu
unterstützen und aber die Palästinenser
nicht wirklich schnell mit Hilfe zu
versorgen warum ist das so kompliziert
warum ist es in den Vereinten Nationen
so kompliziert warum ist es in der EU so
wahnsinnig umstritten wir wissen es gibt
verschiedene politische Hintergründe
aber wer könnte jetzt am schnellsten
dafür sorgen dass die Vereinten Nationen
eben nicht morgen ihre Arbeit einstellen
weil die hamass ist nicht schafft an den
Treibstoff zu kommen na ja man hat
versucht ja in den letzten Jahren auch
Israel hat das ja sehr erfolgreich
versucht ein neuen Friedensschluss
hinzubekommen mit der arabischen Welt
hat dabei mit Saudi-Arabien geredet mit
den Vereinigten Arabischen Emiraten
geredet und da so eine Vision aufgebaut
die für alle in der Welt sehr kom war
positiv auch klingt tut sie ja
tatsächlich das Problem dabei ist nur
man hat die Palästinenser vergessen oder
sogar wie viele sagen mit Absicht
ausgespart und man muss ja dazu sagen
ich kann mir im Moment schwer vorstellen
wie man mit Hamas reden möchte mit einer
Terrorgruppe die diesen widerwärtigen
Massaker begangen hat aber ähm es gibt
das es gibt ja eine ganze millionenschar
von Palästinensern und man darf nicht
vergessen dass es im Westjordanland sehr
sehr viele Palästinenser gibt mit denen
kann man reden und die sagen Leute wir
haben in den letzten Jahrzehnten alles
genauso gemacht wie ihr im Westen das
von uns wolltet auch ihr in Deutschland
ihr habt immer gesagt ähm bekenn K euch
auch zu einem friedlichen Miteinander
mit Israel seid friedlich geht EUR
Arbeit nach ich ich machen z Millionen
palästin absolut ich hab ich hab einen
Bekannten der hat eine kleine
Werbeagentur in in im Westjordanland und
der sagt ich mache alles exakt so wie
ihr das wollt und ihr habt uns einen
eigenen Staat versprochen und der ist
aber nie gekommen stattdessen sehen wir
wie Israel Siedlungen baut Siedlungen
baut und die schon mal die physische
Möglichkeit dass dieser eigene Staat
überhaupt existieren kann uns damit
raubt es gibt diesen alten
korrespondentenpruch wä zwei Parteien
sich darüber unterhalten und verhandeln
um wer welchen Kuchen welchen Teil des
Kuchens bekommt ist eine Partei den
Kuchen einfach auf und das ist in den
letzten Jahren die Situation gewesen das
heißt den gemäßigten Palästinensern
fehlt die Perspektive und die müssen mit
ansehen wie die radikalen die
terrortrups von Hamas die Agenda
bestimmen und wie Hamas in den
Schlagzeilen ist und Hamas am Ende sogar
zu Verhandlungen mit Israel kommt wie in
der Vergangenheit häufiger geschehen um
Geisel aber eben auch um einen
Waffenstillstand z.B während die die
gemäichtten am Ende aus deren Sicht
komplett leer ausgehen das darf nicht so
bleiben wir müssen die gemb MA genau das
Spiel ist deswegen so wie Gott weil die
Frage ist ja wer ist denn die Hamas wer
finanziert die Hamas und beispielsweise
die Rolle des Irans als
terrorfinanzierer also da sitzt ja
sozusagen die Bank von jihadismus das
ist ja sozusagen die unheilvolle Allianz
die die Hisbollah die die Hisbollah im
Libanon so reich gemacht hat die dafür
gesorgt hat dass aus einem jihadismus
eine Sicherheit entsteht ein Geldfluss
entsteht die Spur des Geldes ist hier
ganz entscheidend und die führt nach
Teran und dann wenn ich dann von
Asselborn höre ja wir haben damit nichts
zu tun dann ist das leppisch man kann es
nicht anders sagen also ich glaube dass
ein Bewusstsein dafür hergestellt werden
muss dass vor allem es erstmal um die
Menschen geht vor Ort die gerade
tagtäglich sterben wenn wir keine Lösung
finden aber darüber hinaus ich sie mögen
das wor Flächenbrand nicht aber
natürlich ist der Terror dezentral
organisiert und er ist schon längst in
den Köpfen angekommen und wir müssen
wenigstens dann in der EU mal anfangen
die iranischen revolutionsgarten zu die
Terror das erste unbedingt die Frage
Herr Mölling zwei statenlösung ist die
eigentlich schon tot es wird immer nach
dem politischen Ziel Israels gefragt und
es ist wichtig dass danach zu wägen und
zu wissen welche Kraft kann dann für
Frieden sorgen ist diese zweite
staatenlösung eigentlich aus der nachdem
was Christian sagt so eigentlich tot
ähm also erstens ich bin kein
regionalexperte wenn ich darauf die
Region gucke dann habe ich den Eindruck
es gibt äh so viele Probleme die
ungelöst sind und auch so viele Lösungen
die sozusagen noch nicht implementiert
sind dass ich nicht sagen würde sie ist
tot sie ist möglicherweise wie alle
anderen Dinge wird ständig verschleppt
ähm die Frage ist ob nicht der
alternative Ansatz den die Israelis
gewählt haben wir sprechen jetzt mal
lieber mit den Saudis und versuchen
sozusagen das palästinenserprem Aussicht
der Israelis nicht als erstes sondern
als zweites zu lösen weil wir erstmal
gucken dass diejenigen die in dem großen
Spiel mitspielen also man muss sich das
ja im Grund vorstellen wir haben zwei
ebenenspiel das eine ist sehr direkt
zwischen den israelisen und
Palästinensern ich verkürze das jetzt
etwas und auf der anderen auf der
regionalen Ebene das Spiel zwischen
Israel Saudi-Arabien und dem Iran und
die Frage wer hat eigentlich hier die
Kontrolle wer hat welchen Einfluss und
dann sonitischer Gürtel versus
schiitischen Gürtel genau und dann
kommen die einzelnen Terrorgruppen mit
rein die im Grunde Stellvertreter
sind für den für den Terror der aus äh
den Einzel Hauptstädten bezahlt wird und
so sind auf einmal die beiden Ebenen
miteinander wiederum verknüpft diesen
gordischen Knoten hat man bis langemer
versucht zu sagen wir machen erstmal die
zwei staatenlösung und dann machen wir
den Rest jetzt hat man uns andersrum
versucht ähm hat bislang auch nicht
geklappt Nano hat die zwei Staaten die
Lösung ja immer abgelehnt auch das ist
ja eben leider ein Fakt das war
politisch nicht gewollt und er hat sehr
wohl mit der Hamas zum einen und der
palästinensischen Autonomiebehörde zum
anderen äh ein hässliches Gleichgewicht
halten wollen wenn man in der Region
unterwegs ist und mit den Menschen redet
und sagt das Wort Zweistaatenlösung dann
bekommt man quasi von allen und zwar von
Israelis und Palästinensern nur ein
müdes Lächeln oder auch ein resigniertes
Lächeln ein trauriges Lächeln die sagen
zwei staatenlösung das ist das
Schlagwort das bringen die westlichen
Diplomaten immer wenn sie auf Mission in
der Region sind weil es ein schönes
Schlagwort ist aber ich habe ehrlich
gesagt in den letzten Jahren niemanden
mehr vor Ort getroffen der tatsächlich
daran glaubt mm und es wird vor Ort auch
immer schwieriger man muss sich mal
fragen wie sollen diese beiden Staaten
denn konkret aussehen insbesondere der
palästinensische Staat aus was besteht
er denn eigentlich noch das ist ja ein
Flickenteppich was wir da sehen und wir
haben natürlich auch eine
palästinensische Regierung in ramala die
alles andere als sicher im Sattel sitzt
also da gibt so wahnsinnig viele Fragen
so dass die Menschen vor Ort beim Wort
zwei staatenlösung immer nur genervt
Abwinken und dann wird man eher über
ein ein uninsatz nachdenken müssen und
darüber reden also wichtig ist ja
tatsächlich zu fragen wie vermeidet man
ein Vakuum ein Vakuum in das dann wieder
terroristische Gruppierungen springen
absolut es gibt immer diese diese
Experteneinschätzung dass wenn man eine
freie Wahl machen würde bei den
Palästinensern dieses jah weder im
Westjordanland seit längerer Zeit noch
im Gazastreifen gibt dann wäre im
Gazastreifen aus einer freien Wahl würde
jetzt die Hamas abgewählt weil die Leute
in Gasastreifen gemerkt haben was sie
von diesen Terroristen haben was sie
ihnen eingebrockt haben im westjordan
allerdings würde nach diesen Experten
Meinungen die habamas gewählt weil die
nämlich sagen unsere Regierung hat
überhaupt gar keinen Eindruck
hinterlassen und keinen Einfluss gehabt
am Ende und jetzt versuchen wir es mal
mit was anderem das ist die ganz große
Gefahr vor der wir stehen und ehrlich
gesagt ich glaube aus israelischer Sicht
geht's jetzt erstmal um eins die müssen
jetzt versuchen dieser unmittelbare
Bedrohung durch Hamas in den Griff zu
bekommen und dann noch sehr sehr viele
andere Dinge die sie im eigenen Land
auch haben mit sich selbst zu klären
also da ist eine enorme Strecke jetzt zu
machen ähm bei der ich ehrlich gesagt
ich glaube niemand sagen kann wie es
jetzt ausgehen wird die Situation in
Deutschland hast du vorhin kurz
angerissen die Frage noch mal
und an dieser Stelle unbedingt gestellt
wie konnte es passieren dass wir
offensichtlich
übersehen haben dass auch
Antisemitismus dass ein muslimischer ein
arab Antisemitismus und Fanatismus in in
deutschen Schulen ist auf deutschen
Straßen ist
wie erschrocken ist man darüber also ich
wundere mich dass man darüber
erschrocken ist weil das Thema
Antisemitismus in Verbindung mit
Deutschland was unsere eigene erinerungs
Gedächtniskultur angeht eigentlich dies
rech Antisemitismus hat es immer gegeben
es ist auch ein Linker Hinz linker ein
Israel bezogener und jedweder
Antisemitismus darum geht es doch muss
bekämpft werden und was was ich dort
sehe ist sehr viel lastungsnarrativ sind
immer die anderen das merken wir jetzt
auch gerade wieder damit man sich selber
als Saubermann generieren kann aber wir
haben in diesem Land ein
antisemitismusprem seit diesem
besestialischen Terrorangriff ist es zu
über 202 antisemitischen Taten gekommen
Synagogen sollen wieder verbrannt werden
Mahnmale werden bewacht durch die
deutsche Polizei in unserem Land es ist
beschämend es ist beschämend dass wir
für die Juden und Jüdin kein sicheres
Leben gewährleisten können parallel dazu
gehört auch zur Wahrheit dazu nimmt der
antimuslimisch antiarabische Rassismus
zu das heißt auch hier sind sozusagen
die extrem am Handwerk das ist teilweise
teilweise ganz wichtig hier müssen wir
differenzieren auch selbst gemacht weil
die Bilder die man zeigt die sind halt
da ja beispielsweise in Neuköln wenn das
gefeiert wird was dort passiert wie will
man das Vermitteln da hat man versagt
auf allen Ebenen und das haben sehr
viele Pädagogen schon sehr früh klar
gemacht dass es völlig egal sein muss wo
dieser Antisemitismus herkommt wichtig
ist dass er bekämpft wird und wir müssen
sozusagen auch an die Zukunft in unserem
Land denken jeder Vierte hat
zuwandungsgeschichte aber der
Antisemitismus ist keine Erfindung aus
dem mittleren Nahen Osten sondern ist
ein weltweites Problem Juden werden
verfolgt seitdem es sie gibt und wir
haben eine Menge zu tun in den nächsten
Jahren und wir merken selber auch als
Aktivisten wir haben schon einige Krisen
durchlaufen so krass wie diese habe ich
noch keine erlebt sozusagen auch in der
Polarisierung nach dem Motto wo stehst
du als wenn es sich hier um ein
Sportereignis handeln würde und wie kann
es sein dass unsolidarität entzogen wird
wenn ich wie hier am Brandenburger Tor
eine Solidaritätsveranstaltung moderiere
für jüdisches Leben gegen Antisemitismus
das ist doch kein Nein zum Islam aber
das sind leider die Zeiten in denen wir
leben und auch hier müssen wir darauf
achten dass nicht die Extremisten hier
sozusagen das Zepter in die Hand nehmen
übrigens auch politisch da passiert auch
gerade eine Menge sondern dass wir mal
ein bisschen verbal abrüsten und der
erste den ich daran erinnern würde wäre
unser NATO Bündnispartner Erdogan der
von der Hamas als befreiungs ja als
befreiungsgruppe spricht ja und noch
nicht mal Widerstand und damit zündelt
der das weiß der auch hier leben so
viele Millionen Menschen aus der Türkei
was machen die wenn die sowas hören von
Erdogan wann ist Schluss damit also wann
fangen wir endlich an auch zu sagen hört
auf mit Religion Politik zu machen lasst
unsere Leute hier in Ruhe das sind
unsere Bürger und es geht darum dass wir
diese Früherziehung nicht in die Hände
von verwende legen können die damit
zündeln wir haben eine Menge zu tun wir
machen hier einen Punkt ich darf mich
ganz herzlich bedanken für diese Runde
vor der Sendung vor dieser Sendung habe
ich mit dem Bundespräsidenten ad Joachim
Gauk gesprochen über die Situation im
Nahen Osten und die Situation hier in
Deutschland hier ist das
Gespräch Joachim gaug guten Abend sie
waren als Bundespräsident mehrere Male
in Israel sie kennen das Land gut und
natürlich müssen wir mit dem Nahen Osten
beginnen der amerikanische Präsident Joe
Biden hat bei seinem Besuch im Land
bemerkenswerte Sätze gesagt hören wir
mal es muss Gerechtigkeit hergestell
werden aber lassen Sie sich nicht von
ihrer Wut verzehren so wie wir nach dem
September die USA bekamen Gerechtigkeit
aber wir machten dabei auch
Fehler er spreche aus Erfahrung ist
dieser Verweis auf den 11 September ein
guter
gewesen das überlasse ich mal anderen zu
entscheiden was mich dabei besonders
interessiert hat ist äh dass er nicht
ausführlich darstellt wie grausam jetzt
dieser Anschlag war wie brutal wie
menschenfeindlich und damit äh die
Gefühle der Verletzten Israelis und auch
jeder aller anständigen Menschen noch
einmal
anerkennt und wertet äh und beachtet
sondern dass er seinen Blick in die
Zukunft lenkt und das ist denke ich ein
sehr hilfreicher Gedanke und wenn er so
öffentlich spricht können wir davon
ausgehen dass auf den diplomatischen
geheimen Kanälen vielleicht sogar noch
deutlicher gesprochen wird und das
Interessante ist hier anzuerkennen dass
Israel das Recht hat dass es sich auch
genommen hat im Kampf in der
Verteidigung es ist angegriffen in
dieser Situation darf sich verteidigen
das sagen alle vernünftigen Menschen so
aber jetzt kommt eine neue Perspektive
hinein die Situation vom Ende her zuud
denken und nicht von der Gegenwart oder
nicht von der Vergangenheit und an die
Zukunft zu denken die Israelis sind
immer noch schockiert ob dieses
verlorenen
Sicherheitsgefühls um jetzt tatsächlich
auch für ihr militärisches Vorgehen
kritisiert zu werden Herr gaug darf man
das na ja also die Israelis machen uns
vor wie EOT Barak hat in einem großen
Interview gesagt na ja das ist ja also
ich will keine Kraftausdrücke verwenden
aber es ist eine unmögliche
regierungsleist von
netanahu diesem Land so viel
Unsicherheit zuzumuten und das heißt
wenn wir in Deutschland über Israel
sprechen tun wir das aus einer
besonderen Situation heraus die kein
anderes Land mit uns teilt wir sind
dafür zuständig wir Deutschen also
andere deutsche als wir die Deutschen
vor uns dafür zuständig dass der
millionenfache Judenmord zu einer
internationalen Lösung geführt hat die
den tinenser nicht gefällt die Vereinten
Nationen haben nach dem Krieg aber
gesehen die jüdischen Menschen brauchen
einen Raum in dem sie sicher sind und
haben deshalb diesen Teilungsplan
entwickelt den die Palästinenser nie
akzeptiert haben so also wir Deutschen
werden nicht übermütig werden wenn wir
auch kritische Fragen stellen aber wir
lassen uns doch auch Stützen bei
kritischen Fragen gegenüber bestimmten
Teilen der israelischen Politik von
Israelis selber denn die Israelis
kritisieren netanaho dauernd und sehr
kräftig wir sind das haben sie schon
angedeutet
Angela Merkel hat 2008 von der
Staatsraison der deutschen Staatsraison
gesprochen die Existenz und Sicherheit
Israels zu gewährleisten sie haben das
Herr gaug interessanterweise vier Jahre
später kritisiert sie haben gesagt ihr
Wort von der staatsrison könne die
Kanzlerin in enorme Schwierigkeiten
bringen na ja wissen Sie eigentlich war
eigentlich war das eine Äußerung die
vielleicht ein Bundespräsident nicht
machen sollte denn ich war aber ich war
in einer anfangssituation mir war das
auch nicht so bewusst
äh was ich niemals wollte ist die
Verbindlichkeit unseres
Beistandes in Frage zuellen in Frage zu
stellen sondern das Gegenteil ist der
Fall nur hatte ich die Sorge dass wenn
man sich zu viel vornimmt und das nicht
einhalten kann dass dann so ein
frustrationselement
in die Politik reinkommt und nur jetzt
in dieser ganz konkreten Situation
gefragt unser bundeskanz hat das ja
wiederholt und was heißt es jetzt wenn
tatsächlich der Krieg sich ausweitet
wenn die Existenz Israels tatsächlich in
Frage steht was bedeutet dieses Wort von
der staatsreson dann na ja wir sind so
eng mit der Existenz und der Sicherheit
Israels verbunden durch die Zusage aller
Regierungen die dieses freie Land
gemacht hat dass wir die allerletzten
sein werden die diee Solidarität mit
Israel aufkündigen und äh in welcher
Form wir diese Solidarität ausüben das
hängt auch davon ab was die Israelis von
uns verlangen aber wir werden weder in
den Vereinten Nationen noch werden die
israelische Politik Fehler macht
aufhören solidarisch zu sein es gibt
Fehler die sind schwer zu ertragen aber
noch schwerer zu ertragen wäre es wenn
das Volk derer die Abermillionen
hingemordet haben sich gänzlich abwendet
und so tut als ginge uns das nichts an
Sigma Gabriel sagt mit Blick auf das was
in Deutschland auf deutschen Straßen
gerade passiert ist dass wir versagt
haben er meint damit den
Antisemitismus man kann Herr gaug
Vereine verbieten endlich die Hamas
verbieten man kann samidun verbieten
oder ein bewegungsverbot aussprechen
aber was tut man gegen Judenhass in den
Köpfen
ztausender man bemüht sich anständig zu
bleiben und sich nicht zum gegenhass
aufstacheln zu lassen ich bin natürlich
wissen Sie ich gehöre ich bin im Krieg
geboren und gehör zu den deutschen die
als Jugendliche und junge Erwachsene
voller Schrecken gesehen haben was wir
angerichtet haben was unsere Väter
Mütter und Vorfahren da angerichtet
haben und
ähm in meiner Generation ist ein ganz
tief
verankertes Gefühl wir gehören zu Israel
entstanden um
irgendwas nicht wieder gut zu machen
aber um anzuerkennen dass uns eine
besondere Verantwortung zugefallen ist
und wenn man von solchen Gefühlen
getragen ist findet man das
unerträglich dass hier ein Hass
gegenüber einer ganzen
Bevölkerungsgruppe an gestachelt wird
und in den Familien Kindergärten und
Schulen in ihren Heimatländern gepflegt
wird und das ist einfach unerträglich
ich habe vor Jahren schon darauf
hingewiesen und es war dann immer die
Situation in Deutschland dass wenn wir
über den importierten Antisemitismus
gesprochen haben leicht von links kam na
ja ihr seid wohl fremdenfeindlich und
dann hat es so eine Hemmung gegeben und
man sprach dann lieber über den E
geborenen und autochtonen
Antisemitismus der widerlich war
widerlich bleibt und widerlich sein wird
aber wenn man einen sehr virulenten und
in den Schulen und an vielen Orten
auffindbaren gar nicht mehr ernst nimmt
dann denken die die können sich alles
erlauben und dann gibt's diese Exzesse
wie in der Sonnenallee hier in Berlin
das das ist wirklich eine Unkultur der
die Zivilgesellschaft und die Politik
gleichermaßen entgegentreten muss man
das die Kinder die Jugendlichen die
Aktivisten sind hier in Deutschland
geboren sie sind groß geworden wie kann
man Hass aus den Köpfen kriegen ja
Menschen sind veranlacht zum hassen und
wir werden h nicht weg disiskutieren und
nicht wegzaubern können aber wir können
Menschen lösen vielleicht auch Erlösen
aus dem Gefängnis des Hasses wenn ich
eine Person wie Ahmed mansor anschau
im GR seit zwei Jahrzehnten darum kämpft
dass im Grunde eine solche Bindung an
rentim und Vorurteile auch Leben verengt
und
Lebensräume unsagbar belastet dann ist
es einfach so dass wir diese Liberalen
Geister aus unserer aus dem Milieu derzu
gewanderten dass wir die
stärker stärker ernst nehmen dass wir
uns intensiver mit ihnen solidarisieren
dass wir schauen wo sind die Frauen und
Männer innerhalb dieser milies die
gefährdet sind in Richtung an die man
durch Aufklärung retten kann das ist das
eine dann das andere ist dass in unseren
Schulen ein stärkerer Blick jedenfalls
in diesen Hotspots wo sehr viele
zugewanderte aus dem arabischen Raum
leben dass wir dort das Thema nicht
meiden weil uns es Schwierigkeiten in
der Klassen bringen könnte denn darauf
kommen wir auf jeden Fall noch mal
zurück sie sie haben sich im vergangenen
Monat Herr gaug in die aktuelle Politik
eingemischt sie haben eine Verschärfung
der
Migrationspolitik gefordert war das auch
ein Grund oder warum na ja das nein das
war eigentlich ein anderer Grund äh ich
habe
äh mir Gedanken gemacht über das was
unsere Gesellschaft gerade erschüttert
und eben von außen wie von innen und bei
diesen Erschütterungen von innen ging es
mir besonders darum dass ich als
Vertreter einer offenen liberalen
Demokratie nicht glücklich bin wenn sich
rechts außen nationalpopulistische
Parteien oder Bewegung in ganz Europa
aber auch bei uns so darstellen wie Sie
es gerade tun und äh dann sie sprachen
das dänemarkmodell an bei Dänemark das
ist der der Gedanke äh die dänische
Regierung hat ja eben beispielsweise
festgelegt gesetzlich festgelegt nur
noch 30% migration und migrantische
Kinder in Schulen zu haben und damit
dafür zu sorgen dass es einfach auch
einen anderen
Anteil von ihnen unter allen also ja sie
haben verschiedene restriktive Maßnahmen
beschlossen wir haben auch festgelegt
das Asylverfahren außerhalb des Landes
stattfinden sollen und Begrenzungen
stattfinden sollen aber das als Gedanken
waren wir da naiv waren wir glutorbig es
ist so deutsche wollen gut sein und das
ist gut so dass sie das wollen den das
wollen die besseren deutschen se ja aber
das dürfen wir nicht gleich ironisieren
sondern das ist eine Verpflichtung die
auf dem Land liegt seit das Land wieder
begonnen hat demokratisch zu werden und
aus diesem Grunde sind uns die humanen
Grundsätze ist ist es das Völkerrecht
wie die Menschenrechte so wichtig und
darum ist in unserem Grundgesetz das
Asylrecht so stark verankert stärker als
in anderen und trotz des
asylkompromisses der das Recht so ein
Biss bisschen eingeschränkt hat gibt es
immer noch diese massive Zuwanderung und
es hat sich gezeigt dass in allen
Ländern diese diese Verunsicherung durch
eine Zuwanderung die einem Teil der
Menschen nicht allen aber einen Teil der
Gesellschaften den Eindruck erweckt ich
bin nicht mehr dort zu Hause wo ich
wohne sondern das ist das wird mein
eigenes Umfeld wird mir fremd und so hat
sich gezeigt und das ist gibt's auch
wissenschaftliche Arbeiten da drüber das
ist jetzt nicht nur aus dem bauchges
dass ein bestimmtes Maß an Zuwanderung
dafür sorgt dass automatisch der Teil
der Bevölkerung der Sicherheit wichtiger
mit als Freiheit und das ist immer so
und ein Drittel unserer europäischen
Gesellschaften dass dieser Teil dann
wenn die traditionellen konservativen
Parteien ihnen nicht mehr konservativ
genug sind sich ein anderen politischen
Ausweg sucht sie haben von
Kontrollverlust gesprochen das ist
eigentlich eine Vokabel aus dem sprech
der AFD waren sie da über sich selber
auch ein bisschen erschrocken nein war
ich nicht weil ich habe davor gewarnt
wir haben ja keinen absoluten
Kontrollverlust das ist ja Quatsch aber
wiriert man
Ding ist so wie in der Außenpolitik wir
können vielleicht später noch darüber
sprechen sind uns manchmal unsere guten
Absichten im Wege die bittere Realität
angemessen zu erkennen und wir denken
dann dass wir mit unserem guten Willen
und unseren guten Absichten auch gute
machen können und das geht so lange gut
wie wir eine Akzeptanz von Mehrheiten
für diese humane Politik haben und es
geht nicht darum wenn ich hier selber
mir überlege es müsste Form von
Steuerung und auch Begrenzung geben dass
ich denke das Boot ist voll also wir
könnten wahrlich auch noch mehr schaffen
aber was wir eben dabei leicht verlieren
können und das zeigen uns die Erfolge
der Populisten in den skandinavischen
Ländern die ja super stark sind aber es
gibt einen bestimmten Punkt wo dieses
zuwanderungs diese massive Zuwanderung
so viel
Wandel erzeugt dass die Menschen
abzwitschen und dann fehlt die Akzeptanz
für eine liberale Politik und dieses
abnehmen von Akzeptanz
gegenüber ja und das ist mein Grund
warum ich da reingehe in die Debatte der
Bundeskanzler hat danach den Ton
verschärft und folgendes gesagt man muss
die Kraft haben Menschen zu sagen dass
sie hier leider nicht bleiben
können wir müssen endlich im großen Stil
diejenigen abschieben die kein Recht
haben in Deutschland zu
bleiben wir müssen konsequente
abschieben haben Sie das Gefühl dass der
Bundeskanzler schon weiß
wohin ja jetzt kommen wir zu einem
Problem dass sogar die Fachleute die
sich lange mit diesem Thema beschäftigt
haben sagen ja liebe Politiker ist ja
ganz schön aber geht nicht dazu ist
folgendes zu sagen erstens ist es
wichtig wenn eine Regierung eine
tatsächlich vorhandene krisenhafte
Situation erkennt und als problematisch
begreift erster Schritt zweitens wenn
sie imstande ist das nicht nur zu sagen
sondern daraus Handlung ableitet also
Verordnung und Gesetze schaff wie
beispielsweise ja wie es jetzt gerade
geschieht der dritte Schritt ist dann zu
prüfen ob das ausreicht oder ob das eine
gute Politik ist aber wir wollen mal die
ersten Schritte schon mal positiv
bewerten weil sie zeigen dass plötzlich
ein Bewusstsein der wirklichen
Wirklichkeit in die Köpfe der handelnden
eingekehrt ist und dass dieses schöne
oft romantische oder wie soll ich sagen
auch christliche Wunschbild dass wir so
großzügig sind mit unserer
Willkommenskultur dass uns jeder
verfolgte ein lieber Gast ist dass wir
uns dieses schöne Bild einer politischen
Wirklichkeit durch die Realität
korrigieren lassen und wir merken dann
dass es nicht in der Politik darauf
ankommt nur die schönen Ziele zu
definieren sondern dass manchmal also
ein ein Mann wie der der der Kanzler
Scholz für den ist das doch eine Mühe
solche Sätze zu sprechen da ist auch ein
langer Anmarschweg und er er
beschreibt damit dass Politik eben nicht
nur die Benennung des schönen ist und
des wünschenswerten sondern manchmal ist
Politik eben leider nur die Gestaltung
des weniger schlechten und das das
müssen Menschen begreifen und Menschen
die mit dem politischen Geschäft nicht
so vertraut sind haben dann immer
Probleme damit so eine böse Politik
sagen sie dann zu akzeptieren und
tatsächlich reagiert solche Politik
nicht weil menschenfeindliche Politiker
da sind sondern weil sie Sorge haben wir
können mit einer Politik die wir füricht
halten nur dann Erfolg haben wenn wir
Mehrheiten gewinnen und das wiederum war
der Grund warum ich mich überhaupt zu
Wort gemeldet habe und in dieser Form
sie wollen natürlich die liberale
Demokratie schützen Herr GA sie haben
über die AFD schon gesprochen eine
Partei die in den Umfragen jetzt bei 30%
im
Osten liegt aber auch mittlerweile bei
20% in manchen westdeutschen
Bundesländern Umgang mit der d sie
schließen nicht aus dass man hier und da
auch mit der AFD gemeinsam stimmen muss
aber was schließen sie aus eigentlich in
der Regel schließe ich das schon aus
also verabrehnung über Politikziele
zusammen mit der AFD mit dieser nicht
veren es gibt bei auf der kommunalen
Ebene dauernd Dinge ich sag das ja nicht
so sondern weil ich mich vorher mit
Dutzenden von Bürgermeistern unterhalten
haben wie läuft denn bei euch das seit
anderthalb Jahren so läuft es nicht gut
so und äh jetzt haben wir diesen einen
Fall über den schon ausführlich
debattiert worden ist ich habe ihn nicht
so ernst genommen weil ich keinen
Abschied der Union gesehen habe von
dieser Brandmauer also um es noch mal
deutlich zu sagen eine Union die jetzt
anfangen würde darüber zu reden dass wir
mit dieser AFD irgendeine Art von
Koalition machen wollen äh das wäre das
würde ich sofort bekämpfen und das tut
die Union jetzt auch nicht mm was die
Union aber als Verpflichtung empfindet
und das ist richtig sie muss für
konservative Wählerschaften ein
konservatives Programm entwickeln das
aber nun jetzt kommt die Schwierigkeit
nicht der AFD nachläuft und
Ressentiments produziert sondern ein
wertkonservatives Konzept vorliegt das
den sagen wir mal diesen ver löst ohne
ein Ressentiment ja ja die den diesen
wissen Sie diesen verunsicherten
Menschen die über zu viel Wandel zur
Wahlentscheidung kommen rechts außen zu
wählen weil die sagen ja früher war
alles besser oder das geht ist viel zu
viel moderne dass diesen Menschen
angeboten wird wir können konservativ
sein sogar schwer konservativ ohne dass
wir reaktionär werden müssen oder
garessentiments miteinander teilen und
diese Abgrenzung muss die Union machen
und
dann werden wir sehen wie es kommt die
AFD wird sich ja sowieso jetzt noch mal
frisch machen müssen weil eine neuete
neue Partei auftaucht SAR Wagenknecht
eigene Partei um eine politische
Lehrstelle zu füllen würden sie ihr
wenigstens da zustimmen Herr na es gibt
halt unterschiedliche Formen wie man
Populismus ausleben kann und politisch
gestalten kann und das Problem ist dass
ihre Thematik eben teilweise
verunsicherte konservative abholt und
auf der anderen Seite eine bestimmte
Gruppe von linksorientierten Menschen
befriedigt wie das nach nachher in einem
Parteiprogramm aus sehen wird weiß ich
nicht eine verhängnisvolle
Überschneidung mit der AFD besteht darin
dass
sie es liebt die Eliten im Grunde
niederzumachen und ihnen Unfähigkeit und
im Grunde strukturelles Versagen
vorzuwerfen und diese
elitenfeindlichkeit das ist ein schönes
sammelbeiken wo sich die reaktionäre
unterschiedlicher Farben äh miteinander
verbinden können und deshalb wird äh die
politische Landschaft äh für Leute die
cool sind interessanter aber für Leute
die die liberale Demokratie lieben wird
es heikler sind und auf die politischen
Konsequenzen kann man jetzt noch nicht
schauen
weil die Partei eben in der Gründung ist
aber was malen sie sich aus wir schauen
dann doch in die Zukunft was das für
regierungsbildungen bedeuten kann in
Thüringen und in Brandenburg nächstes
Jahr und in Sachsen werden die noch
komplizierter es wird nicht einfacher
sein die Linkspartei geht schweren
Zeiten entgegen äh sie wäre ja ist ja
nur durch drei Abgeordnete überhaupt im
Deutschen Bundestag vertreten wie wir
uns erinnern und
ich meine in Thüringen haben Sie Bodo
ramelo der imstande ist durch seine
Person äh Wählerschaften zu binden aus
unterschiedlichen milies da könnte es
der Linkspartei noch gelingen äh zu
stehen aber die neue Partei wird überall
im Osten kräftig absahen und äh wie sie
sich dann gegenüber der AFD verhält
das weiß ich nicht ich habe eben auf
eine Gefahr diese sogenannten Eliten
Frau ner das sind die Menschen die wir
in ihre Position gewählt haben wir die
demokratischen Mehrheiten und sich
beschimpfen zu lassen für Abgeordnete
die aus freien Wahlen zu der sogenannten
politischen Elite gehören das ist schon
ein Segen an den Grundfesten unserer
Demokratie das sind nicht Leute die die
Macht okkupiert hab haben sondern die
wir in ihre Positionen geschickt haben
und dann diesen elitenverdruss zu
züchten ich weiß nicht wozu das gut ist
ja sie bietet jetzt Sarah Wagenknecht
schon der CDU im Osten an mit ihr
gemeinsame Sache zu machen sehr
toll das kleinere Übel wird es am Ende
notwendig sein sich zu verbünden gegen
die AFD wir wir wissen nicht wie die
politischen Zustände sind
aber ich bedauere schon jetzt diejenigen
äh die mit einer Partei von Sarah
Wagenknecht koalieren müssten ich sehe
dieses einstwil nicht und äh bin auch
gespannt
wie es gelingt äh
hier ein gemeinsames Programm der doch
ziemlich verschiedenen frustrierten zu
gestalten viele sind ja viele
frustrierte Wähler die den nicht nur
aber viele frustrierte Wähler die den
wählerstamm der rechtspopulisenchen
Parteien in Europa ausmachen und einige
werden rüber switchen wir kennen das aus
dem Osten schon erst haben die
frustrierten Linkspartei gewählt später
dann sind sie rüber geswitcht wir kennen
das aus Frankreich wo die Linke
einstmals unglaublich stark war und
inzwischen marginalisiert ist und
insofern ist da für wagenknchts
parteiland zu gewinnen und für die
anderen ja es wird schwierig aber wir
warten mal auf die programmatische
Ausgestaltung CDU CSU bieten der SPD
jetzt an aus der ampelregierung
herauszuspringen kann man in diesem
Galopp die
Pferdewechsel na ja also das
ist die FDP hat sich festgelegt und ich
glaube ihrem Image würde das wenig
nützen wenn sie in dieser
Situation wo noch gute und richtige
Entscheidungen möglich sind auszusteigen
also es wird wahrscheinlich irgendwo
eine Grenze geben für eine bürgerliche
und freiheitlich orientierte Partei aber
wir sehen auf der anderen Seite bei den
Bündnisgrünen und bei der SPD so viel
Bewegung und auch Wandlung zum Teil
sogar bei grundsatzthemen
äh dass es dann doch für die FDP
schwierig wird einen
grundsatzkonflikt so plötzlich herbei
zuzaubern und außerdem ist
die Koalition auch noch nicht am Ende
also ich gehörte auch zu denen die
manchmal gefragt haben na ja Kanzler
wann kommt jetzt z.B im außenpolitisch
eine Zeitenwende Politik nach deiner
großartigen Zeitenwende Rede und dann
kommst du rübeln aber wir haben doch
Entwicklungsschritte gesehen also das
Vertrauen gegenüber dieser Koalition ist
relativ gering aber es ist nicht völlig
verbraucht ja und vielleicht ist die FDP
dann auch gar nicht die erste die da den
Finger hebt sondern ja eigentlich das
Gefühl hat dass sie in sehr vielen
Entscheidungen durchaus mit Olaf Scholz
sehr schnell einer Meinung ist aber gut
gucken und folgen ihrem Gedanken dem der
Außenpolitik sie haben dem Bundeskanzler
da auf die Schulter geklopft quasi und
gesagt seine Zeitenwende Rede kam genau
richtig Blick heute im mittlerweile 23
Monat dieses Krieges Putins gegen die
Ukraine würden Sie sagen unsere
Unterstützung für die Ukraine ist
eindeutig und klar genug in ihren Augen
äh sie ist jedenfalls äh was die
politischen Aussagen betrifft klar genug
und eindeutig genug was die daraus äh
abzuleitenden Entscheidungen bei der
Lieferung von Waffen betrifft äh äh gibt
es nach meiner Einschätzung noch äh
Möglichkeiten die den Ukrainern nützen
würden wir haben dieses abwarten und
abweggen des Bundeskanzlers auf
verschiedenen Etappen äh gesehen wie ist
die richtige Art und Weise der
Unterstützung und ich gehöre zu denen
die sagen es ist wichtiger die
Erwartungen der Ukraine was ihre
Verteidigungsfähigkeit betrifft zu
erfüllen als darüber nachzudenken
welchem Teil der Gesellschaft in
Deutschland bereitet das Probleme Putins
Angriff auf die Ukraine diese absolute
Negierung von Völkerrecht und diese
brutale Umsetzung eines uralten
Politikstils nämlich das Recht des
Stärkeren zum handlungsleitenden Element
zu machen und nicht den Schutz des
Rechtes das ist so bedrohlich dass es
eben nicht nur eine Bedrohung für die
Ukraine ist sondern für die gesamte
freie Welt und deshalb ist im Grunde
dieser dieser Angriffskrieg von Putin
nicht nur wegen der Brutalität
mit der er geführt wird und mit den
Kriegsverbrechen sondern wegen dieser
Kampfansage an das Modell einer
freiheitlichen Gesellschaft deshalb so
gefährlich und darum gebührt es sich den
Konflikt nicht nur als einen Konflikt
zwischen der Ukraine und einem
imperialistischen Russland zu deuten
sondern auch als einen Konflikt der im
Grunde davon träumt dass das noch mal
geschehen kann was die Sowjetunion mit
Mittelosteuropa gemacht hat die liberale
moderne und damit das rechtsstaatsdenken
auszulöschen und in eine autoritäre und
zentralgeleit
Form von Abhängigkeit und Unfreiheit zu
überführen das ist die kulturelle und
politische Last die die Osteuropäer
aufarbeiten und sie wissen es was ihnen
drohen kann und deshalb sind die Balten
Polen und die Ukrainer auch so
allergisch wenn Sie diesem imperialen
gestos nun begegnen und das war eine
sehr tiefe und ist nach wie vor eine
sehr tiefe und große Erschütterung die
sie auch in ihrem Buch wirklich klug
beschrieben und noch mal siziert haben
Herr gaug nun sind wir jetzt ja aber
wieder in der Situation zu fragen ob die
ob Putin sich die Hände reiben kann weil
es nun eine neue Aufregung und eine neue
Erschütterung in einer wirklich
wundenwelt gibt die alle Aufmerksamkeit
hat ja das freut ihn natürlich und all
denen im Lande die eine so besonderes
Verständnis für Putin und seine Politik
immer noch aufweisen
ist mein Rat schaut euch mal an mit wem
sich der Herr Putin verbündet mit
welchen Verbrechern kriegsbrandstiftern
und autoritären Kräften und wo überall
er gerne wenn er schon nicht direkt
eingreift aber Zwist und auseinander
dividieren braucht um sein kontrakonzept
Gegenüber der freiheitlichen Demokratie
zukunftsfähig zu zu machen er hat ja
wenig was was so eine innere Zustimmung
der Bevölkerung auslösen könnte diese
ökonomischen Erfolge
die etwa Deutschland hatte nach dem
Krieg als es den Wiederaufbau der
Demokratie gab die sind ausgeblieben
dort und der a außenfeinde sind für eine
innerlich verunsichterte Gesellschaft
und eine nicht durch Legitimation
gestützte Gesellschaft immer wichtig
denn sie sorgen für einen zusammenh ganz
verschiedene Leute in Zeiten von Krieg
oder Krise schat sich dann doch die
Mehrheit der Bevölkerung um die
Regierenden und deshalb nüzen ihm diese
Konflikte persönlich bei seiner Art der
machttausübung und dann ist natürlich
trotzdem die Frage ob und wie groß
unsere Konzessionen sind die wir machen
müssen der Westen wir mussten jetzt
Qatar umarmen eine der Finanzierer des
Hamas der Hamas mit 1,3 Milliarden
Dollar auf der anderen Seite war Israel
vorgestern noch ich will jetzt nicht
sagen Freund aber wenigstens auf der
Seite Moskaus weil man Moskau in Syrien
brauchte also wie kommen wir dait
unseren doppelten Standards klar ja es
sind eben nicht immer gleich doppelte
Standards wenn etwas zunächst
widersprüchlich aussieht ich möchte noch
mal darauf zurückkommen dass im
politischen Raum eben auch dann
Handlungsfähigkeit da sein muss wenn wir
das Gute und absolut richtige nicht
gestalten können und sohinderung schlech
ja das ist eben die ist das das noch
schlechteren und das deshalb geht da der
habbeck nicht hin und sagt jetzt gebe
ich mal alle meine Grundsätze auf und
gehe dorthin und mache dort shake hands
mit dem
katarischen Chef das ist nicht so aber
aus einer bestimmten
Nots Situation heraus
schließen politische Kräfte Bündnisse
mit denen die eigentlich nicht zu uns
gehören und deshalb muss man auch noch
mit untergaduell unterscheiden zwischen
unterschiedlichen Formen von autoritärer
Herrschaft und
müssen sehen dass wir auch mit denen bei
den Katar Kataris sind ja auch
Entwicklungsmöglichkeiten denkbar das
ist ein Land dass sich kulturell und
politisch ja immerhin etwas bewegt hat
und ob die auf Dauer einer Institution
die die Vernichtung Israels und das ist
ja das Problem bei Hermas das sind ja
nicht irgendwelche gewählten Vertreter
der Palästinenser sondern eine
Organisation die die Vernichtung Israels
zum Ziel hat und ob man das auf Dauer in
dieser Weise finanzieren wird wissen wir
auch nicht und denn die man sieht das ja
man sieht es bei bei Sport bei Kultur
dass Teile der arabischen Welt eben auch
andocken wollen an die Freiheitlichen
Gesellschaften also da da ist ein
Entwicklungspotenzial was wir bei vielen
Monarchien noch nicht sehen und wenn
einige sich Schritt für Schritt bewegen
sollen man das Befördern aber wir können
nicht nur Politik machen ist du mit
China genauso wir können nicht jetzt
sofort unsere wirtschaftsbeziehung
abbrechen dann wäre ja bei uns das
absolute Chaos nur weil dort eine
autoritäre Form von Regierung
Z Tage getreten ist die wir verachten
diese diese
Allianz von Russland von Iran von China
ähm großen Teilen der Arabis Welt in
Teilen sogar der Türkei die stärkere
machtwererden Herr GA in der Welt weil
es diesen nicht nur diesen Hang zur
Autokratie gibt sondern weil es jetzt
einen neuen Anlass gibt na ja
Autokratien können mit unterlange leben
also das S Regime hat über viele
Jahrzehnte existiert und
manche
Imperien noch länger also wir können
ungutes regieren z.B bei Großmächten von
außen eigentlich relativ wenig
beeinflussen irgendwann kommt es zu
inneren Reibungen in solchen
reichen wo dann eine Veränderung
plötzlich denkbar wird das passiert auch
manchmal von oben sie Gorbatschow wo
eine Verunsicherung ist manchmal
geschieht es von unten als in
Mittelosteuropa die Polen zeigen nein
wir finden uns nicht mehr ab und wir
wissen nicht ja wir haben ein einen
arabischen Frühling gesehen aber noch
die die Zivilgesellschaft dort war noch
nicht starke noch um traditionelle
Formen von Gesellschaft und auch von
Herrschaft nun abzulösen und aber wir
sehen überall Sollbruchstellen auch und
vor allen Dingen sehen wir eins dass
diese autokratischen Regime den
bevölkerungsmehrheiten letztlich keine
gute Zukunft anbieten können sondern das
sind geduckte Gesellschaften die sich
nach einstweilen nach Freiheiten Sehnen
weil sie Freiheit noch nicht erlangen
können sie huldigen ihren Herrschern in
der Hoffnung dass die milde werden aber
tief in ihnen schwäht eine Sehnsucht
danach dass sie auch die Rechte haben
all der Menschen sich frei über die Welt
bewegen können und alles sagen und tun
können was Sie möchten und diese
Sehnsucht ist unausrottbar und deshalb
ist das nicht eine Garantie wenn die
jetzt sich zusammenschließen dass sie
das ewige Leben haben mit ihrer
autoritären Form gegen Menschen zu
regieren jachim GA danke für dieses
Gespräch
heute ich darf Sie liebe Zuschauer an
Markus LZ weiter verweisen der heute
unter anderem Theo Weigel zu Gast hat
und wir sehen uns gleiche Stelle gleiche
Wellen nächste Woche wieder
um 22: wenn Sie mögen vielen Dank kommen
Sie gut durch die
Nacht
[Musik]